so besides uh doing computations with
arrays we'll often want to plot results
and so that brings us to the topic of
Graphics the main plotting library in
Python is this matplot lib um library
and we're going to talk about uh a
little bit of the matplot lib model and
how we can how we make plots in Python
so it is another Library so we will have
to import something we're going to use
this function subplots over and over um
throughout the the labs and it's it
creates for us um a figure of a given
size we'll see later we can get a grid
of figures but the basic format is it
gives us this thing that's a figure
object and a thing called an axis object
and axis the axis object is where we
actually call the make the direct calls
to plots so what we're going to do here
is we'll have a figure and axis we'll
generate some data and then we'll plot
it okay so X and Y are random normal and
we see when we plotted we got this
strange looking mess we probably wanted
a scatter plot here so for that we're
going to instead of using plot we're
going to change the plot a little bit oh
would joined all the points up with
lines yeah yeah it made a line plot
instead yeah which sometimes is useful
but not in this example yes so this
you'll have to so let's see the point
plot okay so we can do that by um
changing uh adding an argument to to to
the plot method
um so if we put an O here this o is sort
of supposed to represent a circle and
that tells the plot method that we
actually wanted a a scatter plot instead
of a line
plot okay um there's also actually a
scatter method if we directly want to
use a scatter plot okay moving on so
this is a big Library there's a very
good documentation for it uh if you have
any uh other questions so we'll often
want to do things like you know make a
nice plot so we'll want to set labels
there are methods for that the set X
Lael unsurprisingly sets the x-label
axis and the rest of them um are pretty
self-explanatory oh so you can make the
plot and then add things to annotate the
plot is that right oh yeah this that
that's a good point that's one of the
the strengths I think of the of the map
plot lib model is that the axis is an
object it's just a python object you can
change it and then it will change what
you know what um what what is
represented in the figure so if you read
display the figure after changing the
axis you'll see those changes um that's
very nice uh so you can de you can make
a plot step by step and plot it in
stages until you until you like it
rather than having to get everything out
at once so the figure object is um well
this is if we had changed something to
axis we can redisplay the figure by just
typing ending a cell with fig so in this
example we're just going to change the
size of the figure it has methods as
well and we see we changed it from from
8X 8 to to 12 by3 so we'll often um you
know we might want to make a a grid of
plots it has these rows and columns
arguments and here we added a few things
uh to the uh to the figure we're going
to we put a plot in two of the squares
there and then redisplay the figure okay
this is not a very interesting plot but
you can imagine if you have a delicate
you know delicate computation to make
you can fill these things one by one and
then redisplay at the end with calling
fig of course for a homework or for
other things for a paper we'll want to
save them there's a save fig method uh
that we can use to to to save the final
answer so that's very nice I mean it's
really important to be able to make
plots easily in in when you do um
statistics and applied statistics and so
having a nice way of laying out plots
and annotating them is really important
so this is very nice
yeah yeah it's a it's a very nice uh
Library um takes a bit of getting used
to the fact that you call you plot
things to the AIS object but um after
and you'll see throughout the labs in
the book that Jonathan's used a
consistent style of creating figures
using this this kind of layout subplots
layout and and so by the time you've
done all the labs you'll become experts
in in using them as well yes yes so this
lab this first lab sets up of several
things that will see over and over again
like the RNG the the default random
number generator we use that wherever we
wherever we create random number
generator so we have reproducible
results we'll have the same way of
creating plots um uh two two big things
you got some pretty plots to show us do
you uh well yeah there's some Contour
plots uh if you like um so here's if we
have a you know a grid of X values and a
grid of yv values and we evaluate um a
function of X and Y we can create a
contour plot with
that one uh show us okay let's show it
yeah and there there's one additional
thing that's introduced here this is the
outer method so
um
so np. multiply unsurprisingly takes
arrays and multiplies them uh the outer
multiply takes the entrywise product of
these two vectors you can also add outer
and subtract outer many standard
functions have these outer methods okay
so it has nice default Contour plots you
can change the number of Contours if you
like um and by inspecting the arguments
of Contour you can find more about that
it's a weird function yes uh okay all
right and one last thing is instead of a
contour plot you may want to just make a
a heat map and that is the image imow
method plots the makes a heat map from
an array of data oh now you showing
off